[Musique]
les enfants bonsoir les enfants avez
vous été sage avez vous été sage
est-ce que nounours a été sage
est ce que nounours a été au patron vous
mauvais blonde à l'on descend voir
nicolas et pimprenelle ils t'attendent
gros perroquet fut le seul top on voit
la petite souris soit bien sage tu vas
faire une blague non s'arrête nous avait
bien attraper quand tu te vrai dans le
pot de miel
et puis cache toi bien surtout il ne
fait pas bon soir la petite compet
nounours ah j'ai connu ça va bien avez
vous été ça
moi je suis toujours sages ont de jolis
souk et c'est fort intéressant
ce soir je ne ferai pas de caprice je
mangerai tout tu songes au lycée petit
qu'est-ce que tu te sourit oui nous tous
mener mon petit 2 retour un peu que je
t'attrape ne mord pas mais les mignonnes
petites souris je vais attraper mais
c'est vrai que les joueurs
viens petit souille je vais te mettre au
doté
tiens c'est son petit ami et non va être
très bien
l'ado vanier
tu te souviens bonne nuit soit bien
nicolas va te coucher 29 vous
accompagneront
[Musique]
bonne nuit czerny de petit feu m'ont
bien le pont vieux rue
bonsoir
apparemment
j'ai tant mieux
on chez eux peut-être l'enfant ouvre la
fenêtre je sors sans bruit les enfants
potes
[Musique]
tant mieux je reprends mon du chou
bon chaumont
[Musique]
nikolov pas pro 2
lou
il
au togo
[Musique]
te voilà mon gros nounours didon
ils t'ont fait une drôle de blague ce
soir nos deux petits amis nicolas et
pimprenelle ça devrait pas trop mais je
les aime bien tout de même aux routes
nounours
bonne nuit des enfants bonne nuit tous
les amis vol de nuit
[Musique]
oh